we have a point P and it moves such that
it's distance from one point is the same
as its distance from another okay this
is from one point it's the same as this
that's from another I'm going to give
you a really simple example so that you
don't get lost in the algebra I'm going
to pick two points such that it is
equidistant from the origin because that
gives you nice neat numbers and let's go
with this guy okay now you might be able
to start to see this in your mind and
I'm gonna encourage you to do that but
more than just seeing what you think it
should be I want to use what I have
recorded in geometry and algebra to show
that is the case so let's give this a go
P is moving around the internet it's
distance from P to R I'm just going to
call that Peter that distance should
always be the same as the difference
between P and a puck right okay so there
you go
this is just me interpreting what this
means right and just saying it's
symbolic
that's all right now I conveniently
already worked out what this is it's
this guy over here
okay what's the distance between peas XY
variable thing and this corner over here
aid it's gonna be very similar isn't it
very similar it's going to be X minus 4
and y minus 0 or squared okay by the way
you guys have seen me do this before
right you know what Y minus 0 squared is
going to be but I'm putting that in so
that you can see where I got it from
namely from the distance we'll go okay
I'm going to square both sides here so I
have to worry about all these square
roots they are both positive numbers to
their problems in I'm gonna get over
here x squared plus y squared just like
a color for this is on when I expand
this I'm being x squared minus 8x plus
16 plus the same Y squared I have on the
other side you care with that you can't
sold canceled all right what else
cancels being Squared's cancel cancel
what am I left with
I've got a deck set skimmer the other
side equals 16 so that means x equals 2
now did you visualize that beforehand
let's quickly draw this guy right so
here is over there this order right
right there so that's GB right and now
I've got Lear or be here at 1 2 3 4 okay
so I want to be equidistant from each of
these and what did you trace out you
trace down this line did you not that's
x equals 2 now this is not just any lion
is it right like it has a special
relationship between Jimmy and Leo right
all of these sets of my opinion all
these sets of points are all Al walkers
of different kinds right there obeying
different imaging metric rules this
particular locus you can see how it runs
right up the middle
right up the middle another way you
could say this is
and on there was always who's the
quickest to get in the middle who wasn't
so where's the kid you want to draw okay
so you've got the midpoint there I admit
sir
the locus that pain is number one it
bisects this interval between leer and
this is LJ right okay so the the
interval LJ it's bisected but not only
that right tell me what else you can see
about this line every single point they
they they should all be equidistant at
least I've hurt because I couldn't um I
can draw all of these points like if
you're one of the examples if you are
standing up here right then I can draw
this line and this line and they'll be
equal then I should be able to draw this
line and this line and very cool and
I've you on and pocket okay but here's
what's important right this line is not
just going off at any whichever direct
direction it wants to write it's at a
particular angle it's vertical because
that interval that LJ interval is
horizontal right so you have not just
the bisector you have the perpendicular
bisector right the locus of all points
equidistant from these two points the
locus of the point such letters is the
perpendicular bisector of this interval
okay let's see if we can demonstrate
this I held your hand through this try
this one now okay I'm gonna give you two
different points okay okay now I want
you to visualize where that is and
anticipate what you think the answer
might be and then see if you can show
the answer is what you expected okay off
we go
you start with this definition of the
two distances and they should be equal
because the question tells you they're
equidistant right and what we're working
towards is a simplified equation so you
break this guy out you expand a whole
bunch of things you should have some
fades right then you're gonna get an x
squared out of this and x squared out of
this so they'll come out and watch right
you're gonna get a wise way to you y
squared here you get the idea okay once
you come up with this equation
yep pretty good maybe sticks okay now
what does that guy look like doesn't
take one to do a really simple graph I'm
gonna go up to six this something like
sir right which is what you should
expect you just have a look at where a B
goes right not bad for doing it by hand
right again you've got the perpendicular
bisector of that interval a B